[Music]
good afternoon my name is luis carlos
covo I lead the wavenet team I did mine
for Google in Mountain View and I
oversaw and worked on launching wavenet
for the Google assistant first in
October last year and that was also
launched to clout later and I'm going to
talk a little bit about what is wavenet
how it works why it is better than
previous approaches for text-to-speech
and a little bit of you know how it
compares with a with a with the other
methods so before we had wavenet there
were the previous approaches to
text-to-speech basically fall on two
categories they usually the highest
quality one was concatenative and in
this type of text-to-speech approaches
we take a large corpus of speech from
one speaker and we divide it on small
slices of a free my a few microseconds
or sorry milliseconds and then the
problem of text-to-speech is just a
problem finding the right pieces of
speech to reconstruct what you want to
say on the other hand with parametric
approaches we build we have a linguist
build a model or a mathematical function
that approximates how the human vocal
tract works and then we learn sometimes
maybe using machine learning how to
drive that model to be able to say the
things that we want to say and to
assemble the speaker that we want too
much so both approaches have come a long
way and they they are good for many
applications but they have some limits
in for concatenating methods the main
issue is the amount of data that you
need to for it to sound good you need
several thousand hours of data so that
you have enough pieces to reconstruct
anything that you might want to say if
you don't have enough amount of speech
you will have to use about Timmel slices
in some situations and that will sound
bad there will be noticeable
these are all glitches in the audio the
other problem is with scaling something
like concatenative doesn't allow you to
generalize across speakers or to do
transfer learning because speakers
between speakers if you have a corpus of
speeds for one speaker you want to add
another one you need as much data as you
need it for the first the same applies
for expressive speech if you want your
speaker to be able to produce speech in
a range of emotions you almost need to
duplicate the whole data set for every
one of the emotions that you want to say
on the other hand it sounds pretty
natural because you're using real speech
but it has these these limitations with
parametric usually we can get away with
with fewer with less data because we
already have a model of how the there is
a good approximation of how the human
vocal tract sounds the problem here is
usually that the speech that is produced
the quality of that speed is limited by
the quality of the model that you have
and these are never perfect so the
speech ends up sounding somewhat noisy
robotic and unnatural here's where
wavenet came in wavelet is coming in as
a parametric model on asteroids where
everything including the human vocal
tract
it's learn in an implicit neural
networks in tation from the data that
you have therefore your the quality of
your speech is no longer limited by the
model that you have but but by the
amount of data that you have the quality
of that data and maybe the computing
property you have to process that data
also this allows us first to produce
speech that it's even of higher quality
than in its election for the same amount
of data and it also allows you to do
transfer learning across across
expressive styles and across speaker so
if you have a large corpus for a
language for one speaker you don't need
as much data to introduce a second
speaker because the model can learn a
lot about generalities of how humans
speak from the first data set and just
you just need to set up a little bit of
seven to fine-tune to learn the
particularity of another speaker so this
allows us to build more voices and
provide more more speakers and more
emotional or specific styles for cloud
customers so demo time we'll see if this
works
so we can hear some real examples from
Google production systems so we're gonna
hear first the unit selection sample a
single wave net can capture the
characteristics of many different
speakers with equal fidelity so as you
can hear it's pretty natural and maybe
it's a bit hard to tell it without
headphones but there's a few releases
that was saying wavenet can capture the
characteristics of many different
speakers with equal fidelity compared
with that wavenet a single wave net can
capture the characteristics of many
different speakers with equal fidelity
now it's fast so we don't have those
bleats is there it may be a bit
difficult to tell the difference with
without headphones I spent we spent a
lot of time dividing these models with
the headphones on but there's a real
improvement in DIF that you can really
improvement in in quality that you can
measure in some ways that we'll see
later with respect to parametric the
difference it's much more clear I think
it will be evident even through the
through the these speakers so this is
one example of parametric a single wave
net can capture the characteristics of
many different speakers with equal
fidelity and wavenet a single wave net
can capture the characteristics of many
different speakers with equal fidelity
so this is where it's fast so these were
two models on the strain on the same
speaker on the same amount of data and
you can see that the wave net1 sounds
much more natural in another language
enjoy a bonito no media no cotton re vos
announced a hawk Aoki who I met a seka
Connie Madero Qureshi mas Tata Nova
bonito no me de casa no cotton Oliver
she announced a hockey
yamete sake econo-mode arrow today
Chema's kong-chi wavenet Tonio won't say
how guess sao gate technique osaka's
master all right now you know how to say
wavenet in japanese okay so what is
waving it waving it it's a neural
network that produce speech the main
thing that you have to know is that
before that before wavenet came around
if it was thought that it was not
possible to generate speech sample audio
sample by audio sample directly with a
neural network because the the time
dependence between in in the in the
audio when you have a high sample rate
like 24,000 samples per second is just
too high for most for the model you
would have to train so how we did we do
it so what you need to do to know is
that when it's in Auto regressive neural
network with dilated convolutions what
does this mean
Auto regressive means that every sample
that you produce goes back as an input
to the system to produce the next sample
that way you create continuous sound
that sounds natural convolutional means
that instead of connecting all neurons
from one layer to all neurons from the
neck to the next
you just connect its each neuron to a
couple or a small number of neurons from
the previous layer and you reused the
the weights of that connection in all
neurons that have the same relationship
that makes the model small enough to be
for us to be able to learn it officially
and finally the secret sauce is the
dilated part what we do is that these
connections that we reuse as we go up
through the layers of the neural network
we make the the neural star connected to
the one in the in the following layer
there are spaced apart further and
further exponentially so what what this
gives us is that the the the time range
that that can influence a sample grows
exponentially with the number of layer
stuff linearly so keeping a small model
with a moderate number of layers we can
get a very high receptive field that
allows us to learn a model the long-term
brain let the long-term relationships
that we need for the speech to sound
natural so this was a very this paper
described his work him up came out in
October 2016 I make a splash because it
sounded much more natural than previous
system but it was terribly slow mostly
due to the outer recive nature of the
model you need to do you have to run a
fairly complex neural network just to
get one sample of audio and you need to
do that 24 thousand times to generate
one second of audio and there's a lot of
optimization that you can do but it's it
was it is not feasible with current
hardware to read it fast enough for a
real-time text-to-speech system that
usually needs to run orders of magnitude
faster in real time so what did we do
so this motivated a new line of research
that resulted in a new paper that is
roughly a year later after the the work
was in production called parallel
wavenet so what we do is that we train
once we train the original wavelet model
we use that as a teacher for a second
neural network that is much faster
this is neural network just States in a
vector of noise and transform it to
sound like the speech that we want to
sound to to to generate that generated
waveform is then passed to the already
trained wavelet model that's course how
likely this is to be speech from a human
being and at the or from the particular
speaker that we want to replicate
actually at the beginning this network
produces just random noise but little
little by little it learns how to
produce audio that pleases the original
wavenet network and that sounds
basically it learns to imitate the
original the original network the good
thing why we go this roundabout way is
that this new need this new network its
feed-forward which means that in one
single path you can generate all the
utterance you don't have to go sample
sample anymore and it's not only faster
but it can be parallelized so you can
chop an utterance in many pieces send it
to different processors different
computers and assemble it and that's
what allows us to get the latency that
we know that we need to make this
available in production systems so this
allowed us actually to increase the
speed of wavenet by three orders of
magnitude so we went from generating 20
milliseconds in one second so
significantly slower than real time to
generate in 20 seconds of audio in just
one second so 20x real time and that was
enough for us to use this in production
and even though we gave up on the auto
regressive nature and and that can have
an effect on quality even this parallel
wavenet still closes 70% of the
perceived naturalness gap between
synthesized and real speech here you can
see these are most coarse which are
basically we have blind tests in which
we send audio of audio samples to people
and they score how natural they sound
from 1 to 5 5 in the maximum usually you
don't get a 5 because people always
think that maybe you're trying to fool
them actually real speech usually gets
around 4.5 and we are able to push from
the the gap between synthetic and unreal
set by by 70% and we believe that you
know further changes in processes are
gonna allow us soon to fully close that
gap thank you so much with this I will
pass to Dan Aharon which rpm in Google
Cloud TTS thank you Thanks
hi I'm Dan I'm product manager and cloud
ETS likely we said and a couple other
products in cloudy I so I wanna
tell you a little bit more about cloud
text-to-speech so first you know this
technology what is it good for so three
main use cases we see used one is in
call centers for automated voice
responses so you know a lot of IVRS
today interactive voice response they
need to pre-record all the prompts so
that they can play them when people call
in with with TTS they can now generate
them automatically and they don't need
to pre-record it it's it's it's they
were forced to pre-record it because
synthesized speech was was not really
that good up until now but now now it
suddenly becomes good enough and the
other benefit is you can you have much
more flexibility in language so you can
insert entities that change instead of
having one script that was recorded
three months ago and then you can't
deviate from it
second thing similarly in IOT if you
want to talk to devices and have them
talk back it's it's a very it's a very
useful thing to have so that that you
you know you can have conversations with
your users and last but not least media
a lot of sort of written media can now
find a new form in audio and you're
gonna hear from Deanna a little bit more
about that in shortly
so then Cloud Texas speech was
introduced three or four months ago it's
part of our conversation group in the
building blocks and and part of our
cloud AI portfolio so if you haven't
already definitely recommend you check
out some of the sessions for other
products there's a lot of really cool
products in in Cali I so cloud TTS as I
mentioned was introduced late in late
March and it's it gives everyone the
power to use the same TTS that Google
does and and that includes using wavenet
voices
you know we fortunately have the ability
to run stuff on GPUs and other things
than we can produce machine learning
based speech synthesis API at scale it's
really easy to use you're going to see
that in a little bit and it's pretty
flexible you can use text or XML or do
all these other things so a few new
things we have for you today first
wavenet up until today has only been
available in English us we now have
seven more languages that are available
so that's that's pretty big it's been
one of our biggest requests from users
so we're very excited about that so it's
now available in English German French
Japanese Dutch and Italian French is not
live yet I think it will be live maybe
next week or pretty soon the second
thing is audio profiles and we're gonna
talk a little bit more about that so
I'll come back to it
so this is now our full portfolio and
voices 14 total languages and variants
and there's 30 standard voices and 23
wavenet voices so across them you get a
you know reasonably global coverage with
you know a few pockets that are me
saying that we're working on on
uncovering okay so the second thing
we're at reducing today is audio
profiles so up until now text-to-speech
produces a single WAV file and then as a
developer you can use that WAV file to
play anywhere you want to whether that's
in a kind of a tiny speaker whether
that's on headphones or whether that's
on a phone line or anywhere else what we
found is that the the quality of the
speaker or the attributes of it can have
a pretty big impact on the quality of
the sound that comes out and so this if
you want to aspire to get the best
quality you should actually have a
different wave form that's sent to each
type of speaker so starting from today
you can actually provide this audio
profile
you can tell us whether it's going to be
played on a handset or on on a home
entertainment device or on on a phone
line and then we'll do the proper
adjustments so here for example this is
an example WAV file and how it looks
like on a phone line so you can see all
of this area there on the left and all
of this trouble area on the right
you don't actually hear them on a phone
line so when you when you try and play
this WAV file it's gonna sound distorted
because you're missing a lot of the
information that doesn't get carried
across and sorry what we're doing with
audio profiles is were compressing it
from the sides into the middle for for
this example for phone line and so you
can see now the waveform looks like this
and you get much more information there
in the middle which which sounds better
and so if I were to play it on my laptop
it'll actually sound worse but that same
wav file when you play it on the phone
it sounds better
okay so with that let me go to the code
lab and the demo let's let's start from
the demo first
so text-to-speech I'm just gonna go to
the news let me make my screen bigger
let's
what's and beautiful let's use this
article and let's just copy this text
and paste it into our new cloud to
speech text-to-speech API and I'm gonna
first play a regular voice so you get a
sense for how it sounds like it's
official Carmelo Anthony is now a member
of the Atlanta Hawks for now the three
team trade sending Anthony Justin
Anderson and a 2022 lottery protected so
you can hear it's a little robotic right
now let's play the exact same thing in
wavenet it's official Carmelo Anthony is
now a member of the Atlanta Hawks for
now the three team trade sending Anthony
Justin Anderson and a 2022 lottery
protected first-round pick via OKC to
the Hawks Dennis Schroder and Timothy
Lucca Barrett to the Thunder and Mike
muscala to the 76ers is official so you
can see it doesn't sound a hundred
percent human but if I weren't telling
you that this is played by speech
synthesis and if you were just listening
to it I would have imagined this is an
NPR reporter or something like it's
official corpus especially as you get to
the second paragraph here Melo Anthony
is now a member of the Atlanta Hawks for
now the three team trade sending Anthony
Justin Anderson and a 2022 lottery
protected first-round pick via OKC to
the Hoss Dennis Schroder and Timothy
Lucca Barrett to the Thunder and Mike
muscala to the 76ers is official it's a
fish okay so let's go to the car lock
thank you
so what we're gonna see next is I'm
gonna show you how to take an audio file
that I have here and we're gonna
transcribe it with speech to text then
we're gonna translate it to a different
language and then we're gonna turn it
into wavenet and play it so there's a
lot of things that could go wrong and
I'm not a very good Python developer so
work with me here and let's try and do
it together hopefully we'll be able to
get through it okay so this is the this
is the simple text-to-speech example
that's on our website and so let's leave
it for now let's come back to it let's
add some code that does transcription so
this is the speech to text sample on our
website I'm gonna copy over these
important statements so we already have
our parse so we just need a OH
and then let's copy all of this
okay and instead of client it's called
speech client okay and now let's give it
a path slash users than documents audio
slash gonna play this file
hi I'd like to help sorry not this one
actually I wanted this one welcome
everyone to the Google cloud next
session for text-to-speech hope you have
a great day okay I'll put speaker you
just eat this one okay stop wave and
then we don't need Samoyed house cuz it
auto detects that the language is in
u.s. let's add punctuation do we have
punctuation here no it's probably in the
beta snippets tong khoo
yeah here it is enable punctuation
equals true so I'm gonna paste it in
here
and let's also use the video model
thinking you do that model are we using
the beta speech or the formal one
okay we need this so it gets the beta so
let me make sure that we're using that
[Music]
Google Cloud import speech or speech
okay great so now we have client
recognized and then it's
printing the response so it's this let's
just run this and see that it's working
correctly and then here linear let's
make this linear 16 and call it output
dot wave wave and then instead of this
text we can do alternative transcript
okay look we can do that later let's
let's try and run this now so Python
let's go to the speech at text-to-speech
directory first Python trying our size
let's just give it a text
okay so as no model field it's probably
not using the beta we can probably do it
without the model but
let's just see if there's oh yeah it's
not it should be speech client let's
write again if not we can remove the
model okay
let's just remove the model
maybe I have a typo there or something
okay let's try this again
okay let's skip that situation just use
the stuff that's not in beta
okay
line
forty-eight here
something's wrong with the audio
version which version yeah it's because
I'm mixing by mixing the beta with the
non beta so let's just let's just use
the regular one we don't really need the
beta okay let's try this now
okay welcome everyone to the Google
cloud next session of the Texas peach
hope you have a great day
so we didn't it's not it doesn't have
punctuation so that means the speech
we're going to produce will not be as
good but that's that's fine for now
okay pick a language guys what are you
feeling today from one of the ones with
wavenet support like this German okay
let's do German so let's go to translate
and let's look at the code sample here
by thumb you don't github will add these
imports
and then translate text was a translate
text here this translate client and
result so so we've done the recognition
now let's translate translate client we
don't need this stuff let's translate it
to German and the transcript equals
[Music]
basically one response
zero dot alternatives 0 and then dock
transcript hopefully I got that right
let's just print it to be sure
transcript
and
transcript and then translate the client
translate texts instead of text whoa I'd
transcript this is translation resolved
and then let's input that text here okay
oh sorry I'm text-to-speech we should
tell it that it's now doing German
instead of English us okay let's try
that okay
cannot import in here I think I need to
go and set up the cloud client install
just about the command
okay let's try that again whoops let's
try pipe and come out again
okay
where is it
it's all curious okay so transfer
people's response zero oh no its
response in result yeah exactly
thank you sponsor results zero let's try
this again now all the things that could
go wrong in a live coding session okay
so we got we got it now there's just
this translated text thing so I think
it's square brackets right yeah
it's result translated text so result
translated text
does anyone here speak German by the way
how can we test if it's actually working
yes no yes okay okay so this is the
moment of truth guys so we are in speech
cloud client and OH
text-to-speech cloud client you should
have this output wav file that's played
Vic listen Alan in there Google cloud
next is it song for text in Shiprock
Ahava - hast uninsured and tak is that
right okay thanks everyone we did it
together with your help so yeah if I can
do it with my poor Python programming
skills that really is a sign that anyone
can so please recommend that you play
around with it see what you can do so
with that let me welcome Deanna thank
you very much thanks everybody for still
being here I appreciate that I'm really
excited to share with you some of the
information about how we can use this
amazing technology so my name is Deanna
steel I'm the CIO at a company called
Ingram content group does anybody has
anybody heard of Ingram pants well yes I
know some of you in the front have
thanked you for the rest of you
Ingram content group it be connectbooks
with readers but what we are is we are
the global content distributor for book
related content and that includes
physical books that includes ebooks and
audio books it also includes providing
metadata to our customers who tend to be
retailers through all channels and it
includes ingesting publisher content so
publisher metadata and so forth and
because we have this ecosystem that
relies on publishers and retailers what
we do is we provide analytics back to
publishers we deal with big publishing
houses the big guys and we deal with
small independent publishers as well as
independent author
our customers are retailers they're
direct consumers their libraries and
their educators I'll go through this
quickly three key themes we're seeing
that make this technology really
reasonable and relatable right now in
the marketplace and where we think
there's a huge opportunity so first of
all the business trends have lent toward
this this technology really coming to
fruition and really making a big
difference the opportunities we see span
accessibility and other areas and then
we'll talk a little bit about how we'll
deploy the technology sorry I'll move
here our innovation so today actually in
2017 we distributed 217 million audio
and ebooks around the world we print new
books or a new book every six seconds
and we print on our high-speed HP
printers about 500 books an hour
we span the globe if we were to look at
all the physical and digital content
that we've produced we'd span the globe
1.2 times the business trends so what's
happening is barriers to entry have
fallen away so several years ago if you
wanted to print your own book your own
memoir or your own educational book you
would have had to write the outline you
would have had to shop it to either
publishers or other agencies and you
would have had to do that numerous times
and suffer rejection hopefully not a lot
but it happened and the average lifespan
to get a book accepted and published
would have taken six to nine months
today it can take up to weeks we have
worldwide distribution capability so we
support 28 facilities either office or
distribution center and then have access
to about 220 countries the business
trends so direct reach and discovery
we work with publishers on strategy so
ideation we've dealt with publishers and
retails retailers through channels for
for a long time and that's our sweet
spot so we help publishers especially
small to independent publishers and then
independent authors find their way to
fill direct distribution to content we
provide analytics so we have advanced
analytics platforms that allow data
visualization and some degree of
predictive analytics different topic
different time but we're getting into
data science in that area and we have
hundreds of publishers that rely on
those platforms to understand how they
manage and
get their business we provide
discoverability so because we deal with
publisher metadata and you're all
familiar with medet metadata we actually
allow publishers to ingest their content
and we help make recommendations to them
as to how to make their books more
marketable and discoverable which is a
big deal if you think about publishers
or even independent authors very often
they're not really aware of how to be
successful in that business they just
know they want to produce that
bestseller we can help them do that and
then finally the metadata that we ingest
we actually sell so we've talked about
monetizing data in previous sessions we
do monetize data and that's a very
important part of what we do okay so
let's talk a little bit about business
trends 181 million adults in the u.s.
read a book per year who here is read a
physical book in the last year okay not
surprising for this audience and that
kind of reflects what we've seen so the
United States population includes about
326 million people and of those about
55% or adults and of those 181 million
read so it's it's resting what we're
seeing is that books in any format about
74 percent of the population reads books
but what we heard and what we thought
over time would happen is that ebook
distribution would eclipse physical
books and we've seen that that hasn't
happened so what we have seen though is
that the audio book the listening to the
audio books has increased significantly
and we're working with partners to
ingest even more audio book content why
for a few reasons
business business trends including
accessibility so for us accessibility is
very important when we think about how
we provide access whether through ear
prints those are two key of course
methods but what we're seeing with with
accessibility is that the US Census had
about nine million people identified in
the United States alone that were either
hearing impaired or they were deaf and
it's a challenge because only thirty
nine thousand Braille books had been
printed if it's a it's a very small
percent of the population and not
everybody has access to Braille nor do
they all have access to to voice readers
what that means is the percentage of the
population that potentially we can
provide access to is significant not
only when we think about hearing
impaired but also learning appeared so
people potentially with dyslexia who
have a hard time reading kids who need
that information translated to them
possibly and also people who for whom
English as a Second Language and they
want to be able to quickly put the audio
and visual together so we find that
accessibility is key for us I'm going to
give you a snippet of what we believe to
be really important and a potential for
us to be able to make this
text-to-speech resonate there are a few
things to think about here first of all
obviously the success around
text-to-speech as you've heard has to do
with understand ability and the ability
to sound natural in the past when we've
heard text-to-speech we've heard very
robotic attempts and you know Bell Labs
and MIT have been working on this
technology for decades but what Google
is doing is really uncovering that in
that natural language sound and so we're
very excited about that
well we believe that book
discoverability is critical and that in
fact partner says that about 30% of all
search is going in 2020 is going to be
done via voice so it's going to be
screen 'less so that's really important
as we think about enhancing book
discoverability and so forth
the demo we're gonna give you here is a
snippet of a book by Leif Enger it's a
book called Virgil wander Grove Atlantic
we'll be publishing it in October of
this year Leif is a New York Times
bestselling author and so we think this
book is gonna do really well so imagine
you're driving you hear an NPR segment
about this book and you think I'd love
to hear a segment before I go ahead and
demo it for you I'd like to give you a
little background on in context on the
book so the book is written about a
gentleman living in the Midwest
he owns a cinema and very old-fashioned
cinema and he still plays reel-to-reel
projection so you'll hear something
about being unspooled his life is a
little bit unspooled right now and what
happens to him will demonstrate a little
bit about how he picks it back up we
will play you a snippet of the first
part
of the book Ingram content Ingram
content alright getting the test version
of Ingram content hello what would you
like read to you Virgil wonder now I
think the picture was unspooling all
along and I just failed to notice the
obvious really isn't so at least it
wasn't to me a Midwestern male cruising
at medium altitude aspiring vaguely to
decency contributing to PBS moderate in
all things including romantic forays and
doing unto others more or less
reciprocally if I were to pinpoint when
the world began reorganizing itself that
is when my seeing of it began to shift
it would be the day a stranger named
room blew into our bad luck town of
greenstone Minnesota like a spark from
the boreal gloom it was also the day of
my release from st. Luke's Hospital down
in Duluth so I was concussed and more
than a little adrift
the previous week I'd driven up Shore to
a popular lookout to photograph a
distant storm approaching over Lake
Superior it was a beautiful storm
self-contained as storms often are
hunched far out over the vast water like
a blob of blue ink but it stalled in the
middle distance and time just slipped
away there's a picnic table up there
where I've napped more than once what
woke me this time was the mischievous
Gale delivering autumns first snow i
leaked behind the wheel as it came down
in armloads highway 61 quickly grew
rutted and slick maybe I was driving too
fast you too was on the radio mysterious
ways I seem to recall apparently my
heartbroken Pontiac breached a safety
barrier and made along lovely some might
say cinematic arc into the churning lake
thank you so we can go on to purchase
the book
okay we'll go ahead and move forward let
me spend a little bit of time telling
you about the technology um the
technology is a combination of Google's
wavenet and Ingram contents core source
application our core source system is
our ebook content distribution system
and we has over 18 million titles in it
so there are two components as y'all
know around audio text-to-speech in the
first part is the ingestion the second
part is the distribution so the way this
works is the publishers we ingest
publishers content we do that today
again we do ebook distribution we bring
that book content into Ingram's core
source and then push it out to the
Google Cloud storage the cloud functions
so step four includes three components
and includes translating it to a WAV
file and then storing it in Google Cloud
this is for all new and changed content
if you think about it book content
doesn't change that much unless it's new
or unless new editions come through the
cloud functions then pull that new
content or the changed content through
cloud sequel into two of our
technologies one area which is a tool
that allows for written previews of
books publishers house it on their sites
and it allows them complete to complete
purchases and the second is our IP page
application which is a
business-to-business solution the second
part of it is also where the secret
sauce happens right so the first part is
translating that text to speak the
text-to-speech and developing that that
wav file the second part of it is when
the sample is collected much like the
sample you just heard we bring it in and
into the dialogue flow Enterprise
Edition and the system parses that data
the title being the key passes it
through the cloud data flow into cloud
sequel which then dialogue flow pulls
that sample out of the cloud sequel
passes it through to cloud functions and
then if transactions are to exist to be
exist or to exist we pull it back into
Google Express for the conclusion of the
transaction so we can bring it all the
way through the sample and listening to
that sample into the conclusion of a
transaction
and we think that that's going to be
really powerful so in conclusion I don't
want to get between you and dessert or
what have you we will talked a little
bit about some of the business trends
and what's happening right now in the
market we talked a little bit about the
changes from physical to e to audio we
talked about opportunities around
accessibility and closing the loop
between people who have needs and people
who and the systems and the technology
today and what we can do what Google's
done with natural language and we talked
a little bit about the technology and
how we support it I think we have about
23 seconds so I'll ask if there are any
questions either for any of us all right
you
[Music]